[Music]
thank you
thank you for being a part of the back
street family for 29 years we thank you
for all the love for all the years Nick
Carter in tears as his band the
Backstreet Boys honors his late brother
Aaron who died on Saturday at the age of
34. I'm used to people coming up to me
oh hi and it's mixed little brother how
you doing so you know it's got like I
said you know I get used to it but Nick
did get me started in this and I thank
him for that very much the emotional
tribute happened during their London
concert on Sunday first they played a
montage of photos on screen and then
Nick's fanmate Kevin Richardson
addressed the crowd
those ups and downs you guys have been
through it with us we've been through it
with you and we thank you for taking us
on that Journey with you we thank you
for being a part of the back street
family for 29 years but at one point
Nick couldn't hold back his tears and
his other bandmates Brian Howey and AJ
rushed over to embrace him guys we've
got a little bit of heavy hearts
cause we lost one of our family members
yesterday
[Applause]
and uh we just wanted to find a moment
in our show
to recognize him Nick addressed the
shocking news of his brother's death
earlier that day writing in part my
heart has been broken he's always been
that brother that's been like a father
figure that's been like I'm gonna push
you the singer also shared a slideshow
of pics with Aaron and added to his
caption quote even though my brother and
I have had a complicated relationship my
love for him has never ever faded I have
always held on to the hope that he would
somehow someday want to walk a healthy
path and eventually find the help that
he so desperately needed if Nick is
watching this right now what would you
want to say I will always love you and
and I will always have forgiveness in my
heart for you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]